bonjour qu'est ce qu'ils peuvent bien
faire qu'ils devraient tous être ça
c'est incroyable
rien par ici rien par là j'ai compris je
les regarde allez peut-être malade j'en
sais rien et si c'est curieux en tout
cas vient d'avoir sa part allons la voir
julie métier
mais pourquoi tu m'as fait une peur
pareil je voulais simplement se demander
si gentils mots si tu n'étais pas malade
je vais te manquer malades de me faire
partie d'un jury se distancer des calmes
toi là et que casimir entourent y est
remonté sur ton dos en train de faire de
grands gestes un truc que tu es devenue
folle non mais non mais non je vous
attendent qu'une heure et je commence à
me faire un souci fou j'étais en train
d'entraîner casimir à faire de la course
à pied sur la plage voilà bon dans le
sable ça fait beaucoup de bruit mais
c'est très fatigant j'ai perdu deux
kilos
où ça ah bah je les ai retrouvés oui
parce que après casimir se sentait si
faible il est rentré chez lui et qu'il a
mangé deux kilos de gloubiboulga et
c'est pour ça que nous sommes un peu en
retard bidon
le secteur n'est pas encore arrivé
pourquoi il doit apporter des paquets
pour moi une surprise pour chacun des
enfants 1000 mais pour moi c'est mieux
bien sûr tu sais bien que tu n'es jamais
oublier casimir
voilà le facteur rouge à venir bien
épuisé le pauvre tester la porte et la
porte des plantes dans les po et c'est
vivant david manque c'est vivant casimir
et si on veut que les fleurs vivre
longtemps
il faut prendre grand soin d'elle bien
bien on va l'aider à les penser par
dépêchons nous dépêchons nous attendent
et je vous ai des facteurs on venait
vous aider c'est bien gentil à vous
voilà vous avez la vitre écoutez si vous
n'avez pas été aussi bavard tous les
deux pour écouter c'est pas grave
bon alors vous voulez vous que je
voulais pas hausser flair et ben moi je
crois qu'il vaudrait mieux les
distribuer tout de suite parce qu'elles
ont besoin d'affection
elle est due à raison julie et j'appelle
les enfants des enfants mérite nous
venez voir regarder la surprise que je
vous ai préparé
regardez ce sont des plantes dans les po
abandonner une à chacun d'entre vous il
en sera responsable
vous êtes d'accord oui françois oui
est-ce que les plantes respire
évidemment casimir les plans trispeed
oui et qu'est-ce qu'elle ronflant
dormant que mureaux telle question
vraiment à elle reçoit ne ronfle pas les
enfants vous avez déjà entendu et
plantes ronfler la nuit mais dubois
casimir tout le monde sait très bien que
les plantes ne refait pas tu n'as même
pas été capable de me répondre tout ça
mon père dit vous disputez tous les deux
vous feriez mieux de bd à distribuer les
plantes d'accord je vais t'aider tient
la première c'est un cyclamen le
cyclamen se trouvent dans les montagnes
surtout dans les alpes
julie comment fait on pour l'entretenir
on la rose tous les deux jours tu la
veux michaela voilà ou alors ça plante
beaucoup plus grosse difficulté
élastique a dit ce qu'on appelle aussi
l'arbre à caoutchouc
ça vient d'amérique centrale qu'un gilet
attention celle ouvrant alors là
l'arrosage deux fois par semaine et il
faut nettoyer les feuilles avec un
chiffon sec tu donnes tu l'as vu toi un
grand voile a alors ça c'est un naze
allez on retrouve les plus beaux au
cachemire entre des azalées de toutes
les couleurs tiens je n'ai alors
arrosage un jour sur deux et il faut peu
de soleil et pas beaucoup de chaleur tu
l'as vu tu peux venir
voilà voilà alors ça ce sont des tulipes
celles ci sont jaunes miren de toutes
les couleurs il a même dit noir les
tulipes ont été rapportés il ya très
très longtemps des indes orientales par
les hollandais
c'est une plante d'extérieur et
d'intérieur aussi on larousse deux fois
par semaine c'est à dire c'est pas
beaucoup et elle ne craint pas le soleil
et le dis tu veux les tulipes tient
lundi
latulippe est une fleur aux oignons
moi je voudrais là à grosses fleurs de
toutes les couleurs là je serai très
gentils avec elle attendre quoi c'est
une fleur artificielle ont quel joli nom
pour une fleur une artificiel dans
lequel le plaisir une plante
artificielle ne pousse pas n'est pas
vivante elle n'a pas besoin qu'on
s'occupe d'elle on françois tu es
vraiment très méchant la julia leigh
tout à l'heure que toutes les fleurs
avait besoin d'affection mais je ne
parlais pas défaire artificielle quasi
rire bon on continue la distribution
allait d'accord
voilà ça cela est bien joli tout ça
c'est un aralia tu ne tournes très
résistante très costaud bien des
feuilles on ira des doigts c'est un joli
alors deux arrosages par semaine et
c'est une plante d'intérieur et
d'extérieur aussi tu l'as vue est
presque aussi grande soif
voilà une jacinthe c'est aussi comme la
tulipe une fleur à oignons
celle ci est plantée dans la terre nous
aussi on peut aussi la faire pousser
dans l'eau on met l'oignon dans un vase
spéciale qui s'appelle avaaz à g7 alors
arrosage tous les deux jours ou deux
fois par semaine si la paire est très
sèche il faut de l'ombre pas trop de
soleil tient un tennis très jolies
plantes d'extérieur qu'on appelle
qu'elle sait holler annoncé jeudi que
fait-on julie n'en reçoit par semaine
l'arrosage c'est une plante d'extérieur
aussi et qui demande de l'ombre qui la
veut tu la lecture les points derrière
plusieurs saveurs espagnoles
c'est de la race des fougères et
autrefois à l'époque préhistorique il
avait des fougères qui était beaucoup
plus grande que les plus grands de nos
arbres actuels
imaginez comment restons là ce podium
mais c'est une race de fougères qu'il
faut arroser un jour sur deux tiers
françois vallet et encore des plantes au
nez voilà vous avez votre petit mode
d'emploi individuel aulas est traître de
la honte s'appelle clivia
c'est une plante tropicale un joli les
magnifiques
alors que chaque fois alors arrosage une
fois par semaine et c'est une plante
d'intérieur
elodie tu la veux et tu sais une fleur
il ne suffit pas de la rose et il faut
s'il aimait la caresser même lui parler
on s'est aperçu il ya peu de temps que
les fleurs avait besoin d'affection et
qu'elle s'épanouit c'est quand on leur
parlait alors qu'elle s'étiolait même si
on les soigne et comme il fallait
et si elle restait seul dans un coin qui
va s'occuper de ces primevères
primevères ça veut dire printemps ça
vient de l'italien primavera en des
primevères y en a de toutes les couleurs
tiens je libye nous comment la rose
alors on la roselle deux à trois fois
par semaine à peu près et c'est une
plante d'extérieur mais qui peut se
garder à l'intérieur tu la veux qu'ils
aient bien voilà mais alors il reste
plus qu'à ma petite arvine au ciel non
non non casimir est artificielle elle ne
pousse pas elle n'est pas vivante
il n'a pas besoin de te qui [ __ ] peut
lui donner s'il n a à aller casimir bas
elle est à toi oh mercy est très gentil
dans la jolie petite are fit en ciel
qu'elle est belle je vais bien m'occuper
d'elle est pour commencer je vais lui
préparer pour son déjeuner un bon
gloubiboulga guerre
[Musique]